our commander Grayson has been talking
about the
Orville and it's very
concerning welcome to sidere your SciFi
TV and
[Music]
mve uh no no longer doing that that got
cancelled we only did three seasons is
it not going anymore I don't know truly
the answer to this
Adrian picki first came into my sphere
of
knowledge um during the Agents of Shield
I thought she was brilliant in that so
when I saw that she was going to be in
the Orville I was very happy I thought
this is an stunning beautiful woman who
can really act and even though at that
time I didn't really know she had such a
brilliant comic timing I knew she'd be
great in this role now I have heard
loads of rumors of about the oral over
the last 12 months pretty much ever
since uh New Horizons ended now even
though officially the show has not been
cancelled I have dropped exclusively the
news that Hulu don't really want to push
forwards with this and actually have no
intention right now the reasons Seth
McFarland is way too busy and simply
doesn't have time to write it and he
insists on writing all of it at the
moment at least I'm going to come back
to that and he's got loads of other
projects on that he is allowing to take
priority so Hulu have delayed and
delayed but as it became more and more
likely that actually Seth McFarland
wouldn't be returning in any major way
to the new show as apparently that was
one of the negotiations that he would
write it but maybe not appear in it too
much then Hulu really became less
interested now I very recently actually
this week dropped the news on you that
one of my sources has told me that there
are people at Disney though that are
still very keen for this to come back
they desperately want a fourth season
and they desperately want to keep Seth
McFarland as much as possible in the
fold they know that this show could be a
major franchise and they want to give it
the
chance but I have had a little bit of an
update on that before we listen to
Adrien picky's own words in a recent
interview I just want to give you that
update and
apparently this rumor didn't make sense
to me initially until I actually heard
adrianne's interview so this is
basically what the rumor is that Disney
do want this to come back but they want
it to be a regular streaming series they
want 10 or 12 episodes annually they
want at least another Four Seasons they
potentially they want a TV movie and
they're even thinking about could they
do sort of like spin-offs they do want a
lot more of the comedy to come back
something that was maybe a little a
little bit lacking in New Horizons they
want something more like the first two
seasons they saw funnier and maybe lower
budget that is the rumor I'm hearing
currently and apparently that's what
Disney are hoping to get in the future
if the Orville is finally renewed now
why do I say that rumor didn't really
make sense to me when I first heard it
it didn't make sense to me because I
thought it was too obvious I was like
well obviously they'd want it to be a
regular annual series obviously they'd
want as many episodes as they could and
to be honest them going back to more of
the humor from the first two seasons
also made sense to me because it's the
humor that made the Orville stand out
from other the sci-fi shows it did even
though the third season was brilliant it
did become just another Sci-Fi show a
little bit um in the third season
whereas the first two seasons were its
own show even though it was a love
letter to Star Trek I don't think um
Seth mcfallen ever really tried to hide
that he desperately wanted to do a Star
Trek series wasn't allowed so did the
orille
instead but it was still different it
was still Seth McFarland Star Trek now
one of the things Adrian picky was
talking about in her interview was how
they only got to do three seasons in six
years we shot 33 episodes in six years
33 episodes in six
years how is that possible
mhm you can really tell by her face here
and the way she is reacting to Michael
rosenbom the
interviewer her frustration at the
Orville how they were signed on for the
show they were being paid very little
for an awful lot of effort and that
basically some of the actors were
borderline starving during production
and at one point we were like we have to
like fight the studio like give us a
holding fee or something because you
know Jay Lee was eating Saltines and
Gatorade at one point because we just
couldn't afford anything that should
never really be the case for a major TV
show on a major Network like Hulu Etc so
H what went wrong well obviously we've
had certain delays now because the
strikes and before that there was a a
little bit of a pandemic but even before
that there was a long time between
season 1 and two of the Orville no it
became an actual real issue because
there would be so much time in
between uh between Seasons because Seth
wanted to write
everything um himself so it would just
take so much time I think her
frustration here again is very obvious
she talks about how he insists on
writing everything and that really does
lead into what I'm hearing about any
future orille that Seth mcfar will be
taking a big step back even though it
will still be his production company
even though I'm absolutely certain he'll
still be heavily involved in writing and
I'm certain he will still appear at
least a little bit the rumor I'm hearing
is that there will be other writers that
Disney will insist on this being
delivered annually that it will have to
become a regular show and cannot be so
sporadic it was it was taxing it was
taxing for for what you got out of it it
was it was it a lot of work for right
little now when Michael Rosen bomb first
asked her about the Orville she didn't
say it's cancelled she didn't say she
would never return but I think her words
are heavy she says I did three done now
you've done all these shows and you're
doing one now and uh it's you know it
has to deal with space and a ship uh
that no no longer doing that that got
cancelled we only did three seasons is
it not going anymore I don't know truly
the answer to that I think that there's
the talk that it could possibly be
something that certain people want to do
now that does sound very much like
Adrian picky has no intention of
returning to the orille now she does go
on to say how much she loves the orille
the crew her family and how much she
adored much of the actual show I
actually think what they produced she
adored but she didn't enjoy the process
okay so I did I did love so many things
about it I think it was the process that
was hard the process was difficult but I
love the people I work with it is true
that all the actors are actually on
three season contracts they do not need
to return for fourth season they are not
contracted to do so and it does seem
from here that Adrien Peli is going to
stick to that and it would take quite a
lot for her to sign on for another
series what would it take I think
basically they would have to agree to
allow her to do other projects they
would have to agree to allow her to
maybe take the lead which is something
I've been told is kind of the plan
anyway that if Seth mcfar steps back
that it would be Captain Grayson and
that I think she would need maybe a
little bit of involvement behind the
scenes maybe producer credit mainly it
seems to be that she just wants to be
paid for the work that she does and I'm
absolutely certain that the other actors
would feel exactly the same way so if
the show does return what from the
rumors I've heard and I have to very
clearly say again these a lot of these
are rumors because nothing's been
decided until anything is decided I'm
just talking about the people's opinions
opinions in the industry and opinions of
quite high up Executives in a few
different places what would the show
actually look like though based on those
rumors I think there would be a quite
significant change in some of the cast
I'm not sure for example if we're going
to see Gordon Malloy again I think Scott
ryes has moved on to other projects and
I think even though we probably will see
him I'm not sure he would be a regular
cast member I do think that if Disney is
serious about this they do need to get
Adrien picki back on board and they do
need to pay her and I think that if she
gets the role she would come back as the
captain I think most of the other crew
would return but I think this show will
only return if a deal is struck with
Seth McFarland that basically means he
will release the Reign and that he will
actually allow the writers to come in
that he will maybe stay on as an
executive producer and hopefully star in
at least a few episodes but that he
would take quite a big step back but
guys what do you think about this
interview with Adrian picki does her
face really tell the whole story her
frustration really isn't well hidden and
do you think the Orville deserves a
second chance even if that means that
Seth McFarland has to take a step back
and other writers Etc are brought in
could that actually be a good thing for
the show in the long run I suspect so
but what do you think get to the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out
you'll never miss any of our future
videos also please go over to
patreon.com sidre or most of our videos
Premiere first and you get to see them
without the advert you also get a free
gift after three months you lucky
bunnies also go over and check
c.co out that's our dedicated website
where we do articles based on a lot of
our stories and we try to add a little
bit more information in there for you to
digest go check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time